[Music]
chuck
yes 30th anniversary of the hubble space
telescope
at the launch yes it is oh yes and i was
not going to take that one alone
okay we have to get the big guns for
that that's right right here
professional help
say it that way i need professional help
i have issues i'm trying to resolve uh
jennifer weissman a friend and colleague
thanks for coming up to my house my
pleasure excellent excellent and she
works at the goddard
uh we got a goddard here and i always
confused
here in new york is the goddard
institute for space studies
studies which focuses on like planetary
atmospheres and weather and climate
right the goddard
space flight center in greenbelt
maryland that's right thanks for coming
up
my pleasure for that and you specialize
in regions of
star formation in the galaxy that's
right we
i use uh with my colleagues different
kinds of telescopes to study how stars
are continuing to form
in our galaxy all right nice there you
go see
well let's just i just there's some
backstory for the hubble that i think is
we could get out in this in the next few
minutes 101
hubble 101 so let's do it so first uh
what's
how big is the mirror on the hubble
telescope the mirror
or we sometimes call it the aperture but
the mirror is about 2.4 meters across
that's about 96 inches something like
that yeah yeah
midnight so that's not very big nothing
we have much bigger telescopes on earth
so now so that's amazing so then
why not just use a ground-based
telescope
the reason hubble is because we got some
big ones exactly you said 2.4 meters
we got five meters we got 10 meter
telescopes down here there you go right
and they are wonderful those telescopes
on the ground are terrific
and there's going to be even better ones
in the future bigger and bigger
the mirror size gives you a nice bucket
for sensitivity but the reason hubble is
is so tremendous is that it is above
earth's atmosphere because our
atmosphere does two things to light
coming in
it actually makes it blurs the images a
little bit
because of the turbulence in the
atmosphere and it also filters out
some of the wavelengths of light that
we're interested in seeing
and so by putting a telescope in orbit
around the earth but above most of the
earth's atmosphere we get much
sharper images and much
better sensitivity in some ways as well
so that's why hubble is so
good so the hubble was launched from the
space shuttle
and was limited to the size of the cargo
bay yeah the
the the size of the satellite and and
the width of the mirror that could fit
in that satellite so
that played into the decision of how big
hubble could be
chuck have you been to the air and space
museum in washington i have
okay they have a model of the hubble
telescope there it's the size of a
greyhound bus
yeah okay so let's only 94 inches
yeah go go look at what that looks like
but you got to admit you throw a bus up
in the space and it's
nothing still
go tell that to robert goddard you saw
it
nothing i just keep going how high up
does it orbit it's just about 340 miles
above the surface of the earth it orbits
the earth about every 97 minutes
okay nice and so so
can you observe when it's in sunlight or
do you have to wait until it's
on the dark darkened side of the earth
well it simply cannot point
toward the sun or or anywhere within a
certain
something like a 30 to 40 degrees around
the sun
no we would never do that but as long as
we're pointing far enough away from the
sun
at an angle right then we can look
anywhere we want in the sky
the sun in the sky even with the sun in
the sky but the big problem actually is
because hubble is in what we call
low earth orbit because that's where the
space shuttle also operated
right it's not very far from the surface
of the earth which means the earth
looms large in the sky for hubble so
so we can really only at any moment we
really only have about half the sky that
we can look at and a lot of times the
earth is
in the way of what we want to look at so
when that's the case
during the orbit we do other things we
do calibrations we try to use that time
well
when earth is in the way and again
hubble's orbiting very quickly so every
97 minutes it does a complete orbit so
we don't have to wait long for hubble to
get back into the
view of what we're trying to study in
deep space and so
for i remembered i'm old enough to
remember that space-borne telescopes and
these sorts of objects they had a life
span of
three to five years you launch them you
get all your data as quick as you can
right and then it dies okay the
batteries die
the the what something goes wrong but
you knew that the engineers would know
that
so here's hubble we're celebrating its
30th anniversary this is
factors of 10 longer than other
telescopes so what gives us that
well because hubble has basically been
refreshed over and over again by
astronauts who went up on astronaut
servicing missions
so we and it was designed for this so
hubble was launched from the space
shuttle with
astronauts uh doing the deployment and
then we've had
five missions over the years since then
where astronauts have gone up on the
shuttle connected with hubble in orbit
for a few days
the astronauts would take out old
instruments put in new science
instruments
connected with i just got a picture of
that so you have the shuttle coming
there's there's hubble
in free orbit around the earth right the
shuttle has to catch up with it yeah
intersect it yeah and then that big
canada arm is a robotic
there's canada arm that comes out grabs
it
grip
and then they can work on it without
bumping it or right floating the
astronauts would come out
during these servicing missions would
suit up to get out of the space shuttle
and
and do what we call evas extra vehicular
activity while they're suited up in
their spacewalk
yeah good nasty ease but it's space
walking did two syllables right
okay they would uh take old instruments
out put new science instruments in
repair
i mean some of them are modular so they
were designed to be more easily removed
and replaced some of them
you really have to open up a door into
the guts of the telescope to do your
repairs or and i
i have to say that these people are
heroes the astronauts and also the the
many many engineers and technical
experts on the ground who designed
these instruments and also some of these
tricky repairs that the instruments were
never really designed to to take but
somewhere yeah right
some some parts got swapped out they
were not originally part of the swap out
planes
right right hi i'm mike massimino
welcome to this old telescope
more than one of the repair machines oh
sure yeah and he's a fan he's a friend
of star talk
good these missions take years to
prepare for so
so the actual astronaut servicing
mission is kind of the culmination of
years of preparation
so that's why this telescope has been
basically been made brand new over and
over again in a sense
through these servicing missions time
and time again which is why hubble
30 years into its mission is still very
fresh and in fact
it's actually more scientifically
productive now than it ever has been in
all of its mission because of this and
also because of innovative ways we're
using it one last quick thing just
and we got to end this info bit so we
see these beautiful images
and but scientifically
isn't it true that the beautiful images
are not as useful
to the scientists as they are fun to
look at for everybody else
we use both images and what we call
spectroscopy
to get information whether we're looking
at solar system objects or galaxies or
or these nebulae the images are
important because we use different
filters to see how much
flux how much light is coming in general
in different wavelength bands and that
teaches us something also about the
distribution where it's distributed
but the spectrographs right because if
there's a part of your nebula that's
giving one kind of light
and you filter for that then that'll pop
in that image exactly
right exactly okay but we also use
spectroscopy and some of hubble's
instruments are
really better at spectroscopy than
imaging so that's like taking the light
and spreading it out into its
constituent colors and frequencies
we have two sensitive spectrographs on
hubble right now
and that gives us much more detailed
information for understanding the
composition
of let's say galaxies or nebulae or even
the atmospheres of
exoplanets and exoplanets and it tells
us also the motions of things if we can
see a a frequency of light let's say
coming from hydrogen or something that's
shifted a little bit from what it's in
motion it means it's in motion so we can
measure the motions of material swirling
around black holes
why don't people love this stuff man
this stuff is so awesome how can
people not everybody should this is all
we should be doing
i'm sorry i like that that's cool i like
your attitude this is always something
going on
okay chuck just blew a gasket sorry
before his head
explodes i just lost it this is so damn
cool
jennifer weisman thank you thanks for
being here yeah chuck we got we got
the they're coming for each other right
the guys the white jackets are outside
right now
all right star talk info bit thanks for
tuning in
[Music]
you